let's move on to look at the topic that
we were discussing earlier with hannah
thomas peter in the show about those
five companies who are suing governments
around the world for a potential loss of
profit because of climate action
policies so should governments be
responsible for compensating loss of
businesses or even even jobs and what do
you think about this mohamed i mean
energy companies suing
governments for the damage that
their policies are having on their
bottom line they've got a point
no actually they don't energy companies
suing governments for enacting climate
policies is like a drug dealer in a
former addict for choosing to quit for
example heroin it's just ridiculous
we've got ourselves addicted to fossil
fuels and if we don't stop this dirty
habit it will kill us
you know rewarding companies that have
got us into this mess is absurd
i think instead what we need to see is
governments and especially governments
uh you know in climate vulnerable
countries which we should be suing these
companies for reparations for causing
the climate crisis in the first place
not these companies at all but you've
also got to consider haven't you jen the
pretty ruinous impact that when a
government decides to put an industry
into managed decline the impact that
that has on on the regions that were
dependent on that particular industry we
saw it didn't we in the 80s under
margaret thatcher's move to to to um
to remove manufacturing basically from
from our economy
government should support workers that's
not the same as supporting companies i
mean i'm sitting in wales we know what
an unjust transition looks like when an
industry collapses and there's no plan
so we need a plan for a just transition
that can involve retraining that can
involve some safety nets to make sure
that workers can have high-quality jobs
that help climate-proof the future
but i mean fossil fuel companies are the
most profitable companies on the planet
and they already get taxpayer money
through subsidies
they don't need more of our money but
the workers might need help and probably
will need help in finding high quality
jobs of the future yeah i mean
retraining re-skilling is going to be
essential would you agree with that
mohammed
yes i think we need a just transition
towards environmentally sustainable
economies and societies
at the end of the day i think we need to
tackle environmental social and economic
problems in a coherent and integrated
manner i think a just transition of the
workforce and also creating decent work
but also quality jobs i think is crucial
so that we can be able to ensure public
support for the long term emissions
reductions and climate resilient
development we want at the end of the
day what we're all working towards is
actually delivering a healthy
environment for all of us and if the
process is going to require that we
actually transition away from high
carbon jobs i think what we need to
ensure is actually participatory and
representative processes
where we have social dialogues with
workers and and we can actually be able
to assure them that they won't lose in
the transition in fact they will gain
and will have more jobs going around
okay well we are out of time i'm afraid
it's fascinating talking to both of you
hearing your perspective sir muhammad
adu and jen allen thank you very much
indeed for your time on sky news this
evening
you